oh yeah hey there welcome to honest
trailer commentaries the show where we
talk about the honest trailer you
hopefully just watched and then you come
back here you see our real thoughts or
feelings are true true essence of what
we believed about this movie yeah if you
stick around to the end you'll see some
deleted scenes today's feature oh I
should introduce lon hey probably now on
Dan's not here today lon helps out on
this and rights and and pitches jokes
and stuff on pretty much every honest
trailer since I think Jumanji yes one I
worked on yeah Jumanji and you are like
you know you're the professor man you
just get so many details so many facts
in there like so super appreciate it oh
thanks it knows because I do cram it as
well so like I've often watched the
entire franchise going in to be honest
trailer which is help yeah yeah as
always just our myself but it was really
helpful to talk to you be to bounce
Halloween stuff off you because you've
actually seen every Halloween literally
just watched nine previous more I
watched 11 because I also did the Rob
Zombie man the movie were talking about
today though is the reboot cool I think
we settled on what it is it's a reboot
of Halloween 2 because Halloween 1 does
exist this isn't a Halloween reboot even
though it's called Halloween right this
takes place after Halloween 1 but it
replaces the original Halloween 2 which
took which is set like the same night
yeah so it's a reboot cool it's a
rapport but we mentioned to when we were
working on this that h2o already did a
pretty similar thing 20 years ago where
they realized soon as the first one
exists right well they they assumed one
in two exists just for complicate things
further so they were like the first two
Halloween's happened none of the other
sequels happened we're gonna follow up
on that but even like fanatically it's
kind of similar so let's break this down
first we can get in it cuz this didn't
even make it to any drafts I don't think
was the Halloween universe timelines no
splintered into like eight different
it's like a collapse cult averse it's
completely insane yeah
they've done to this poor franchise
there's one that's like one in the new -
then there's one two four and then
there's all right because Halloween just
really the original Halloween 3 was
gonna be
they were like enough Michael Myers
let's do an anthology and every new
installment will be a different like so
it'll have a Halloween element so like
the first one was a stalker killing
people on Halloween night and then the
next one was gonna be Halloween masks
which are haunted um which is it so they
did a whole movie
nobody was because what people really
loved about the first film was the
holiday Halloween they just wanted to
come back for more stories so what do
you guys think about this one I'll go
first I enjoyed it I thought it was a
fine film it didn't change the game of
horror forever but I thought that it was
a nice oh ma / advancement of the
Halloween story which made for a pretty
lame honest trailer we wrote it I mean I
I liked it but I was I was hoping it
would especially after reading all the
reviews and hearing all the buzz that it
was gonna be this like exciting new take
on it it's very similar to a lot of
other Halloween sequels I was kind of
hoping it would maybe get a little bit
more away from recreating moments and
shots and stuff referencing the first
one I mean we've had a lot of other
movies that have gone back in reference
that first Halloween I just don't know I
would have rather seen them do something
that was a little bit more different in
with it and the movie itself actually
made for a great trailer I remember the
trailer of this being like okay all
right here we go like I hold up the mask
at the chessboard but I think it that
scene just ends basically that old scene
in the preview yeah I liked it and then
it just kind of starts to really
disappoint in the third act which it
wasn't enough to make me just write off
the movie and be like this was terrible
mmm but it was it was frustrating lake
we're going to New Directions we're
going in like here's all the interesting
things we're setting up and then they
just don't execute the things they were
trying to set up yeah
house and then that was the element I
was gonna say in the beginning you think
you're gonna get a really cool third act
where Laurie has done a ton of legwork
to like finally we got a person who
really knows how to fight Michael Mayer
yeah and truly turning the tables I
think the issue for me is like then the
perspective should have shifted you
should have been following Michael Myers
at that point right and Laurie would be
the person in the shadows and and the
traps would be it surprise to you but
instead like she was just as panicked
and kind of outmatched as proportion was
that was kind of the whole thing where
it's like you had this you've been ready
for this your whole life and then
immediately she's just like it's like
the comparison that we made which
immediately jumped out of me even in the
trailer with Shara Connor in Terminator
2 where they took this to character who
was like victimized in the first one and
now she's really become like she knows
what she has to face and is like risen
to the challenge but they don't do that
in Terminator 2 she doesn't like scream
and patter she's like a bad I like she
trained and we feel like through the
Linda Hamilton performance we get that
she's a different person now and I
didn't I didn't get that his Laurie talk
stuff but I didn't really buy it and she
seems just helpless as soon as Michael
Mayer shows up yeah and maybe there's a
there's a theory I have that maple will
get into during the trailer but let's
let's run it let's run Halloween 2018 HT
give us like a second just keep rolling
we got a wire issue so take a pride okay
I got it
here we go okay play it I got thoughts
get this tangled you guys like to please
kill bed all right cause that initial
line is one of my favorites that Spencer
has graduated from from Matt - please
kill me
- please kill me is great okay moving on
wow this is still going I am let's go JT
it's just you and me man
why is it busta rhymes more of a movie
star he's great and shaft he was great
in the Halloween movies he has the
endless he was great as a weird
post-apocalyptic folk hero in the remix
- turn it up parentheses fire it up and
if you've seen any of his music videos
there's a lot of performing and acting
going into those as well alright a back
hey welcome
so who's the best rapper turned actor I
guess it's Will Smith Smith there's a
pedestal but then you think it's a
wide-open field I think T and Q both of
both of your ices make a strong prices
what about your Cool J's gonna run actor
he's been in stuff I like he's good in
things like I think he's tea light he's
like like diet tea because he's now on
one of those like NCIS show right let me
this if you have put out a rap album are
you a rapper it has to be first before
he's directing so then today Mark
Wahlberg Oh Mark Wahlberg John Cena
wrestler album actor now Shaq what order
did Shaq go in who did he wrap before he
was in films but after he learned
kung-fu be known for rap first right
Tupac also John seen Tupac yet Tupac was
actually Paco's rapper reacting
fantastic in nothing but trouble dan
aykroyd lassic trouble
he's a background dancer in them he is
this is a tough question ti he's great
in the wasps yeah okay yeah we're
already kind of so I admit for mr. robot
Joey badass right yeah but sadly I think
that we're coming to realize that Busta
might be in the bottom half maybe in the
middle he's at least in the middle just
an injustice that I feel like needs to
be fixed somehow somebody somebody who
does need to write like a Busta Rhymes
vehicle like what he has John wick
[Laughter]
okay keep God only one creative twins
and restore the Halloween franchise to
its former glory Kenny Powers and the
director of your highness to David
Gordon Green he's directed with some
great movies we were talking about your
type I think your highness is great
you're honest is great but people don't
know that he was like an arthouse
director first like he did George
Washington which is a big like festival
hit and all the real girls was Zooey
Deschanel which is great like so he's
done legit stuff before Apatow and the
boys guys yeah The Sitter and that that
stuff came that stuff came with I will
also say you know like eastbound and
Vice Principals or legit as hell oh yeah
they do dark rear oh well they live on
that edge and they look better than your
average TV comedy that's for sure he's
found it down yeah it looks great it's
really like they're like they're like
indeed little mini indie films blueish
you ready for a smashed-up reboot of the
original or rather a reboot of the
original sequel or maybe a new take on
h2o I don't know man but this time
there's even more carnage for jumpscares
and even more those stupid fake out jump
scares that end up being something else
there were more than we included in this
room yeah we just stop with that it's
like a comedy stick with you to get a
laugh it's cheating the doctors are
still shady yeah this guy man what
doctor sir technically named him dr.
Satan yeah he's like the SAT AI n oh
that would have been a good starring
yeah it's just the the medical care I'm
really starting to question in this
universe of Haddonfield they've got
problems on both sides they're
stigmatizing mental illness and they're
stigmatizing mental health professionals
yes and like anyone that thinks Laurie
should get help is wrong she's a hundred
percent right and like dealing it no one
needs to actually deal with like their
paranoia or their violence there's
actually they're trying to do and it I
think it relies way too much on the meta
of what we know what what the audience
knows and loves about Michael Myers is
the thing I saw them trying to do in
this was that if you if you start to
obsess over Michael Myers enough than
like you just want to you you just can't
get enough that's like the the
podcasters are obsessed with the case
the doctor has now become obsessed with
what it's like to wear the mask and like
the problem with that to me is that like
he didn't do anything super crazy in the
first one and like it relies on it kills
like five people or something and one
night yeah but like a lot of people have
and they don't that bad
like 911 you guys Joe's gonna die in the
next day I don't know I think it relies
way too much on like you also knowing
and being really into Michael Mazda
because I think the meta miss is saying
like like you're never gonna get
satisfying answers as to like why he is
this way you know something that would
explain Michael Myers behavior that's a
that's a fool's errand and by extension
looking into why anybody is bad to other
people is like is a waste of your time
yeah so yeah no no I get it
but yeah I don't like the implications
for mental health and into health
professionals because they're all crazy
or murderous or yeah over the entire
Halloween franchise there really is a
strong like anyone who investigates or
looks into mental health even if they're
directly hoping to help other people
they're gonna go crazy or they're
already bad or like why are they so
curious about evil and it's like you
guys really don't believe there should
be like therapist to help means even the
criminally insane and was something with
the with the mentally ill in this movie
got left on the cutting room floor or
something but there is at some point
just the wacky misadventures of Michael
Myers and everyone else from that from
that prison driving around in a stolen
van just having having a good time yeah
yeah the dream team it was called
Michael Keaton and plays Michael Myers
malice yeah the predator
I do think would have been more
effective if he's just in his own secure
facility he's the only one being prison
transferred once the moment you throw
them in with a bunch of other folks it's
like well I'll tell you what if I'm
running Smiths Grove and we've got a
transfer Michael Myers I'm not doing it
on October 30th you know I even like
obviously there were a lot of sequels
that were retconning out of existence
where that goes really wrong so he
didn't learn from that experience but
just generally by the way if it's been
40 years I'm gonna transfer him it seems
like it's working yeah box wait for
Passover or some other time what he
doesn't have a strong personal
connection you know I'm being
transferred was it was it hospital being
like torn down there is a line of
dialogue that implies that he's been at
Smith's Grove so that dr. certeyn could
like observe him and like you're not
getting any result right and now it's
been 40 years and you don't have a cure
for evil yet so we're sending him to the
to the worst century you know the great
where it's real brutal and that would be
I don't study it a big good Halloween
movie it's a actually yeah at Myers goes
to jail yes Mike Myers in Supermax
or camp scared stupid yeah any of these
any of these the cops are still useless
whatever going to Halloween yeah that's
what you're gonna do it I have a curfew
I mean it's like kids don't need to
trick-or-treat at night at least when
there's a serial killer who kills on
Halloween loose yeah it's a it's a real
like jaws mayor moment it's like we
don't need the jaws mayor in this one
like you could just cancel Halloween
yeah okay it's not hard hey there's a
curfew and to make it up to you we're
doing a trunk-or-treat on say this is a
Halloween town we need Halloween dollars
it is but if you're not gonna do it
after Michael Myers escapes how about
one Jamie Lee Curtis is shooting into
people's homes on the street say like
what are we going to cancel Halloween
what about the crazy lady with a gun
tell those five kids to stay home
tonight
yeah yeah there's so maybe that could
have you could have leaned into the
we're all obsessed with Michael Myers
even more and like the town has now like
every Halloween it's like here's the
Michael Myers tour mm and you know there
is a there is one of the Halloween
sequels that does that where it's like
they've it's become like Michael Myers
Ville and everybody's sick of it you
know interesting now I also want to talk
about I like to call check-offs cowboy
too small for to make it Leon's trailer
but if you introduce a character like
this in suburban Illinois with a giant
cowboy hat you want to say at some point
like ever since you transferred up here
from Texas or it's gonna like I'm John
Wayne either reffers or he's gonna like
lose it but then find it again at the
end you know it's gonna be a thing or
he's gonna come back at all
is gonna come back we had discussed it
to the other example would be if he'd
like does magic yes you know what you
can't introduce something like that and
then not it's got to pay off yeah it's
just so strange like this guy needs a
little bit more of a character like put
a hat on him literally literally but
then it's so much it's too much of a
step forward cuz then I thought we were
gonna follow that guy I thought he was
gonna be with pop we fall yeah you see
this seem definitely makes you think
this guy is gonna have something to do
because it's so specifically about
introducing him yeah I thought because
other cop is so pro Laurie he was gonna
be like the foil of that and the three
of them are gonna be walking around he
was gonna be like oh this is crazy
right like the sheriff from the first
movie where it's like are you sure you
don't have me out here for no reason
yeah you gotta have that conflict or
something just then he went away with
his hat there was no second or third act
hat yeah reference nothing with a hat
we're not necessarily the biggest fans
of black hat but if you're gonna
introduce a black hat in your movie I
think you just gotta you gotta follow
through with it I talked about the Chris
yeah it didn't work it didn't work it
didn't work move on go go go go go
it hasn't changed at all except for a
recent boom in Asian food robbery I do
like mommy sandwich bond me is
essentially just the Vietnamese version
of a French baguette thrill as we were
you everyone gets a little bit of flavor
down yeah I really I don't know there
was stopped for duty I really didn't
like that character it's only based on
like this one scene and he's in one
other scene but I don't know if it's the
act or just like the zing he's putting
on this province he certainly is really
obnoxious well he got the really most
elaborate kill of anyone ever yes
everyone else just gets kind of shoved
into a post but he turned into like oh
is he the one that pushed the head no no
that's the doctor these be like the
flash blue reed-like becomes Hannibal
Lecter for that one sham I think this
was the audition for everyone oh man yes
red the bunny French baguette see
because it's just like I mean imagine if
someone in your life was like hey ever
had a balmy sandwich you're like no no
it sounds like well bond me is actually
just the Vietnamese term for a French
baguette you'd punch that person it's
hard you would not like that perfect
right is good being me there's this and
then there's the kid who's like that I
don't want to go to football practice I
want to dance and yeah and yeah I guess
the dad too is there's a peanut butter
on your penis dad
it's a everyone gets a thing just one
this is my McBride on the couch is like
throwing out stuff like wants dance but
also here's the thing is that French
baguette should be had guy that should
be hat cop that's a weird hat cop thing
where he going he's good he's going on
about bond we say typically yeah they
the law of the economy of characters
would be you don't just randomly
introduce a ton of characters you're not
gonna neat you'll have one Corky yeah
and this movie sort of ignores that is
just like just introduce more carriage
that supposed to be Captain phasma cool
outfit that I never delay trader shoes
like Captain phasma that guy should be
black save it for the sequel all right
keep going mega thrill
bang-bang escrowed once they literally
bribe her to be in the movie
how does $3,000 sound no no podcast in
history has had $3,000 to pay a singer
gasps that's a hell of a patreon
beautiful podcast right sir you know how
many nature boxes you have to sell
started broadcasting yeah but while some
families spawned over brunch and spa
days Lori will bring her clan together
the old-fashioned way by turning the
tables on their relentless stalker in a
finale that will be you wondering okay
she had 40 years to design a trap house
and this is the best she could do a
shotgun and roomful of mannequins and
hit a second Oh No why are they
anatomically correct so yet the the trap
house thing which is a funny coincidence
psycho trap house it's a yeah it's a
psycho trap house but it's also you know
in the trap but it is literally a trap
house heard her plan at the end she has
like a like a panic room underneath the
kitchen island yes like that yeah and it
seems like the plan all along was to
send her own daughter
down into the panic room for safety
assumingly
and then lure Michael down into it with
her and then scoot out around right we
were I think I actually figured this out
okay rewatching it um gotta watch it
twice for the third a that's right
there's that every room in the house is
more than us every room in the house is
set to blow you know she set those like
yet lame things in every room and every
room has those like it's a sliding
portcullis
so she's not necessarily counting on
I'll trap him in the basement she's like
I'll trap him somewhere and then like
the whole house keeps not working and it
keeps not working okay so the base
wishes likes her last attempt okay like
I've got this one last sealable room let
me get him and do it yeah but I don't
think the plan was always get him in the
basement I think that'd be room that's
what she's doing when she's walking
around the house in every room is she's
like I'll find him in this room I'll
jump out seal him in and then like and
then like the whole house on fire again
though I still have one nitpick with
plan which is you can't be there to see
him die correct you have to just take it
on faith that the unkillable stalker
monster will have ya not found a way to
get out of your rickety old house right
time it burns which I have a feeling he
did well I mean they're doing that so
that if they want to do as he got out of
a window because even there's that shot
at the end which I don't think they
should have done where you see the
basement on fire and he's not there yeah
you don't need that we get it you can
bring it back okay so that fair
explanation because I was also
frustrated by that oh yeah the first
time I saw it I was like was like why
why hide that room you don't maybe
wanted to get in it you don't make the
room when you're trying to learn also
the only room that's keeping you safe
dingus yes not with like a plan but even
here's a five pickled vegetables
you notice I you never get a feel that
like oh the tables have turned Michael
because you you think the suspense is
gonna build from the fact that it keeps
not working he keeps not working keeps
not working and then the house has taken
out of the picture all together and then
you're back to basics maybe right but
not like right out the gate it's it's
just very standard issue she's hiding
behind a flimsy wooden door and of
course he's gonna punch in and he's
gonna he's gonna grab that's why you've
trained for and you should have expected
had trails of blood leading to the
closet yeah the fact that you have a
mannequin room in general we were whole
plan is to horse a murderer into it not
just the mannequin room but then
meanwhile like the granddaughters like I
thought her performance was great and it
was kind of like okay cool rad new
scream queen and then like the only
thing they really give her to do is just
run around and yell in the woods she
stabs him yeah it's a good stabber until
then it's just like screaming at
mannequins in the forest yeah you said
something we didn't really address in
the in the trailer I did like the like
intergenerational kind of dynamic of the
three of them anymore I think they
should have leaned into that harder like
yeah that stuff works and I didn't
really like Judy Greer character through
most of the movie until the end yes cuz
most of movie she's being like you're my
okay she was through a trauma like
a little bit of understanding yeah but
like Laurie
up at the restaurant and starts drinking
from someone's wineglass she's like okay
mom like I wouldn't do it but your mom
that they were trying to kind of make
these parallels of like the the
different traumas that these women were
going through throughout generations
like Laura strode horrific you know snow
and stuff like that and she inflicted
seemingly bad things on her daughter
raising her the granddaughter it's like
my boyfriend put my phone in the case oh
you know what when you were in high
school that was trauma that is
traumatizing I mean when I was in high
school your phone was just like the
thing at your house that in case so
that's what were you doing in my bedroom
you had one in your room you had your
own line I did not have my boiled I'd a
landline yeah with the did not have a
line but I did have a phone in my room
like anyone used it I also remember
having to open my bed regarding yell at
somebody using the phone if I was needed
to be on the Internet yep that is yeah
yeah I got a level up in gemstone good
all neat activity to crap their pants
you can run you can hide but actually
you could he's not much of a mover now
say goodbye yeah you just you familiar
who site and the moment that you break
sight is when you can like Benny's in
front
I'm I'm still curious I would love to
ask David Gordon Green is this like rise
all the sudden mean emphasis on your
shocking things instead of stood ready
to meet the real monsters in town that's
not a criticism it is scary and weird
watch these twits open the film by
recording what would have been a
terrible series complete with tons of
background noise this made me mad this
is this is actively annoying like you
could never record yourself like that
well driving I mean first of all have
her operate the mic if you have to do it
while you're doing for you absolutely
because they're also they're recording
like intros and interstitials like wait
till you're back at the studio so you
know script that out and then later get
some room to or some car tone yeah layer
that another totally don't need to like
be on the way they're holding it while
you're driving
are we misinterpreting this and assuming
that because they are serial podcasters
in a movie that they're good at it they
say they've worked for like National
Public Radio like there supposed to be
some grand been around yeah yeah I felt
like this was supposed to be yeah like
it's this American lifestyle got it and
that the movies just doing a very
increment job of presenting what podcast
yeah it was a fine line I think they
should have been like twenty percent
more obnoxious for us to really be
rooting against them and like I can't
wait for them to die instead of like
well they're slightly annoying but the
movie is taking them seriously as our
window into this world ya know if it was
like two idiots who hosts like a cryptid
podcast that they want to do a special
episode about like right like that would
be great it's much better then their
incompetence is part of the joke right
but this they just seem incompetent I
mean if if like I steer really into the
weeds on podcast production just like
know how a microphone works yeah like
you don't hold it this far we've move it
while you're recording yourself our
audience is all audio files yeah the
sound is even remotely weird on movie
fights they're very angry it's true yeah
nobody would listen to this keep going
no to stay
this monster not going ahead to secure
their biggest interview we're making a
podcast pointing their mics if I said
it's bad you should say it's mostly on
producing prepared come on hello anybody
ever heard of SEO uh just awesome CEO
true crime podcast about the murder of
the true crime podcasters though now
that's a season of serial so suit up for
a progressive horror film about women
fighting back against the men who
traumatized them with the undercurrent
that people with mental illness are
scary and violent and Schamberg Emory
Holloway forever that's there is no the
second best film in the franchise just
by doing what the first movie did again
what Samuel is really talking about it's
a specific English class you never you
never had lengthy week-long discussions
on the abstract concept of faith and was
the fate in high school more faith days
doing things the first movie did in
Reverse
[Music]
I hope they also make time for like trig
we're gonna be real behind
yeah I feel like they must have thought
conceptually that this stuff was gonna
go a lot further because it was just it
was just uneven cuz it was sometimes
some areas like you know able to do
magic and sometimes she wasn't like yeah
just fully commit fully commit to her
being the badass killer and and Michael
Myers being the victim or or not or
don't ya she's specifically structured
this to play head games with him and
she's trying to recreate everything into
her because it's like maybe I just know
the first movie to well but about
halfway through once I figured out what
they were doing you can call the shots
like Oh she'll fall off the roof and it
he'll look down and she'll be gone and
like you know it's it you kind of give
the game away and then there's not much
more to it now my fan theory of I think
that Laurie busted Michael Myers off of
that bus I think she caused the bus
accident because there's a scene where
she is like she's drinking and washing
dinner thoughts on the bus leave its
before she shows up at that dinner drunk
yeah she's she's getting a little hooch
DUP and she's watching them load up the
bus and and then earlier or maybe later
she tells a somebody that's late or she
tells the will Patton the cop I pray
every night that like he'll get away so
that I can yell him myself
I like I like his line if that it's like
that was a dumb thing to pray for like
like now you've done it your prayers
couldn't pray for some glory he's really
taken that seriously
that should have been in the movie yeah
I like that I'm not sure cuz she seems
genuinely like upset when she hears the
news report about the bras yeah leads me
to think she didn't know it was common
well I don't know cuz they're also like
a toner reshoots on this movie so at
some point that might have been it yeah
or she's just dissociated and forgot
that she crashed the bus yeah also also
an interesting idea it's like a split do
we think that last shot of the the
granddaughter holding the knife and is
like is that just like a symbolic
passing of the franchise to her or do we
think she's gonna be the next killer or
Jamie Lee he'll be the next killer for a
daughter I'll have to think after
worse past but it was an odd enough
truth - like really linger and on minute
that it was a little little weird
they've done that they had Laurie's
Laurie's daughter in part for at the
very end becomes a murder I'm so sorry
you had to watch others for Halloween
forum this is like when Dan had to watch
all of old school whoo yeah no it's not
sorry I don't want to compare it's
nothing like that was way worse keep
going they switch it up and have Michael
Mars hot Laurie whoa wait story Clint
Eastwood okay Michael
well first of all that's Arrested
Development but think about it for Clint
Eastwood we don't know who Judy Greer is
dad is she just kind of makes these
allusions to failed she said yeah she
had two husbands and their graduates
divorced so we're assuming it's one of
those yeah could this be a was like
Kowalski like a Gran Torino
a Laurie Strode nuptials produced Judy
Greer because I would watch that
crossover yeah I'd see that get out of
my house and get off my life okay keep
going
okay Michael say goodbye to these your
next sassy magazine sassiest I love that
reference obligatory horror movie stoner
Sam is Marcus Garrett and Sierra Cage
you must dismember this how did this get
slayed how about two dope screams this
American knife okay okay one more wait
wait don't kill me
your favorite recent I got it's so weird
it's just cuz you can't toby huss and
you got to give him say yes he's wearing
pants so weird
it's a we it's weird cuz later he says
his pants so he doesn't carry the joke
through it was like I gotta go wipe this
off my pants
yeah so I guess if you spilled like
water on your crotch you'd be like I
spilled water on my dick maybe but you
say your pants like I spilled water all
over my pants yeah yeah I this is a kill
your darlings thing where like you got
to look at the things on your script
that you're like and those are probably
the first things that needs to go I
don't know sometimes it's that I feel
like there are some times where and I've
written myself into this corner before
where you've written a scene and then
you get to the actual set you're gonna
film it and you realize like the
characters don't have anything to do
they're just standing around talking
which looks weird so there's there's a
often a director will be like make a
sandwich yeah what are we gonna what are
we gonna happen to it so I almost feel
like this might have been one of those
like what is he doing he can't just be
standing there he's got to be doing
something okay you could be sitting up
rat rows and all of that was just like
filled in retro thing no I mean that's
another kind of check house rat trap of
like oh well surely he will help with
the construction of this it's so random
that's why I think it was like a on set
that day they were like he's just
standing here at this island in the
kitchen we got to give him something go
get some mousetraps he's setting that
mousetrap that's why I ain't anything I
read I used my improv training and all
seen start with someone digging a hole
really I go with mixing a bowl I have a
gun Halloween - okay so when they make a
sequel to this movie are they gonna call
that movie Halloween - cuz this movie is
a sequel to the original replacing the
original Halloween - so the next
Halloween - would actually be Halloween
three and my nose is bleeding
I can't keep tracking again it would be
Halloween - again I do want to shout out
if we can go back to the the title
Halloween -
if that's even doable I just want to
compliment Holtby because he created
that man he's good we don't deserve him
now yeah that looks good yeah Isaac yeah
super good anyways great job pumping
alright see some deleted soon yeah hey I
get it man
get your sixties and you got to conserve
that energy hey Mikey
just gonna stand there and stare me I'm
starving Laurie get your gun Laurie fell
button they don't get serial killers
[Laughter]
yeah Feldman yeah we did this over the
phone you're just like Laurie Feldman
and I figured just like Oh sounds like
yeah I was like that it needs one more
level yeah men now I guess this was
funny because it's Fox News or someone
on the conserve a sphere was like some
dummy Jamie Lee Curtis uses a gun
disagrees with letting everyone have gun
it's just it's such an internet thing of
like oh you critique society and yet
participated in hypocrite yeah it's just
that same dumb argument anyways yeah I'm
sure she a lot of actors they wasn't
done I'll personally do it was guns she
wrote a tweet that was like I just don't
understand why we can't get guns out of
schools and then somebody wrote her back
like don't you appear in movies where
people shoot other people it's like yeah
she's against the wall and yet look what
else is in that picture wait a minute
True Lies features numerous terrorist
characters so I'm not saying look you
draw your own conclusions saying she's
in red crimson we get to make one us
city each week okay keep God perpetually
concerned bombs you
we're always a concern my pleasure Judy
Greer do you like our Judy Greer finally
get something though we in Halloween age
Bible writer Bob the next generation I
hope the Nelsons don't have a family dog
[Laughter]
Halloween 10 Halloween 2/3 this
courtyard is a massive waste of space
unless they play human checkers y-you
were right yeah there's that scene where
she like apologizes for everything she
did for her growing up but she really
should have been training her more
that's a real like it's a it's a pet
peeve of mine but like it's when they
know the movie has to arc but they
didn't they didn't actually make that
arc but then they just write it as if
they did anyway like everybody learned a
lesson forgot we got a Ming comes now
it's like yeah Laurie you didn't you did
not learn anything if anything it should
be Judy Greer apologizing to Laurie I
should have paid more attention in
marksmanship class because again that
that is sort of what happens in
Terminator 2 like Eddie furlong at the
beginning is like my mom's crazy I don't
want to be around her and then at the
end he's got to be like mom was right I
love my mom thank goodness she's here so
like it almost should have been that but
then they have the mom apologize yeah
yeah there's um again like overall idea
I really liked it but there's just so
there's just a lot I think that gets
lost in the execution like you need that
moment of after the family unit has
stood united against Lori so many times
like starts to go down in the dads
look well and then Judy like things kick
in and she like takes over and she's
like no this that we're gonna do this
this this and this and her husband's
like okay oh because they give her that
one moment where she grabs the gun and
she's like pretending to panic and then
Michael shows up and she's a gotcha it's
great I really like that moment I wanted
more of that yeah agreed
you saying that there's reshoots
make sense cuz it was a good movie and I
liked it it just wasn't cohesive you
know some some threads get picked up and
dropped and you know cowboy hats don't
get addressed I think that's our final
thought on Halloween can't recall it
2018 yeah can't leave dangling cowboy
can't leave it now can't leave a
dangling hat let that be and then please
join us next week we will be covering
another reboot of a franchise I think
it's more like a just a direct sequel
yeah yeah but much worse than this one
so come back next week I'm Spencer Shay
Gilbert at lon Harris thanks for joining
us Joe star we'll see you then bye-bye
[Music]
you